we are really excited about everything
that we've shown here tonight but I know
there are a lot of you who are really
here or really wondering about fallout
76 and I'm pleased to tell you that your
wait is finally over ladies and
gentlemen here's a recipient of numerous
Lifetime Achievement and Hall of Fame
awards he's the game director at a
studio that has won a bevy of accolades
and awards and he's here tonight to tell
us what he and his team have been taking
so damn long to tell us all about will
you please welcome my very good friend
mr. Todd Howard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're all here
looking good oh it's great to be back at
e3 thank you thank you so much I could
not be more excited to be here I want to
thank all our fans who came out tonight
and the millions of you watching online
we can't thank you enough
this is actually my 25th year at
Bethesda and I have seen I have seen a
lot of cool things in that time I gotta
say tonight is definitely definitely one
of them I got to go to the very first
III right here in Los Angeles I know
they're so cute when they're little
they're full of energy and life and then
remember one little III ran away from
home went to Atlanta yes you a lot of
you didn't come
I liked Atlanta or East Coast's and then
III went through the the Moody teen
years and came back and locked itself in
its room remember it was in the
Convention Center but just in the
meeting rooms they didn't invite anybody
and I can remember literally walking
between the halls and seeing nobody I
was like this is how a zombie movie
starts and now III has grown up it's in
its 20s it's more confident can handle
its alcohol better like all of you thank
you
[Applause]
so there's a good there's a good party
after this so pace yourselves I hope
you're comfortable by the way I'm gonna
be here for a while and III has become
such an incredible week of entertainment
but we know that most of you came here
for one thing
thank you
[Applause]
I think it's to see where we're putting
Skyrim next well I think we have the
best one yet
the elderscrolls speak of the past and
the future
now Skyrim looks to the future to its
ultimate version
Alexa play Skyrim your level 57 and see
a tall snowy mountain climate now Skyrim
and life become one a mud crabs cuddles
tore this world off I didn't catch that
grace man I didn't quite catch all the
way to so Vanguard what happened
FUS ro dah that's the command for
knocking things over is there a command
for picking [ __ ] up ever reach that
level yet I'm sworn to carry your
burdens whoa the dragon unleashes fire
breath on you okay
you have 7% health left Ouma [ __ ] I
drink a health potion you are out of
health potions oh how many wheels of
cheese do I have left
473 can i eat all the cheese I eat all
the cheese
hey hon um remember what the doctor said
about dairy yes right yes of course
you're the greatest thank you so much I
ate a introducing Skyrim very special
edition also coming soon to etch a
sketch Motorola pagers and your Samsung
smart refrigerator a sled news oh that's
cool
[Applause]
had to had to do it had to do it okay
really
we both know why you're here and that's
to talk about the next fallout fallout
76 is a prequel to all the other games
and it's our biggest one yet it is four
times the size of fallout 4 set in the
hills of West Virginia you are one of
the first to emerge into an untamed and
very different wasteland
[Music]
[Music]
300 years after our great nation began
we gather together to honor the
completion of vault 76 this sprawling
underground shelter may have been
engineered by vault-tec but it was built
by you so that if the bombs do come our
way of life will endure
almost heaven
West Virginia
it's Mountain
I use all
[Music]
the tree
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Music]
for when the fighting is stopped in the
fallout are settled
you must rebuild not just walls not just
buildings but hearts minds and
ultimately America itself
[Music]
in volt 76 our future begins
[Applause]
vault 76 one of the very first vaults to
open was built to celebrate America's
tercentenary which is a awesome word by
the way
like that's your word of the night
tercentenary you are one of the very
special few selected to be an occupant
and spend 25 years underground waiting
for reclamation day the day
the vault opens good morning bout 76
this is the overseer I hope you all
enjoyed the party last night
even those who may have overindulged and
overslept but it's time to get up and
get out there we've been locked away
long enough
today is reclamation day oh don't you
remember time to leave the vault it may
be time to leave but I'll never forget
the day you all entered vault 76 you
come from every walk of life every race
color and Creed but you all share one
very important trait you are this
country's best and brightest but more
importantly you'll always be my family
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we always start with the world and this
time it features all new rendering
lighting and landscape technology it
allows us to have sixteen times the
detail and even view distant weather
systems across the map
now most people don't know West Virginia
that well it is an incredible array of
natural wonders towns and government
secrets this is where the actual nuclear
secrets are and the quest the overseer
sends you on will take you through six
distinct regions each with their own
style risks and rewards there's plenty
of cool new fallout creatures and we
even use the folklore of West Virginia
to bring our Fallout versions to life
[Music]
we have always wanted to tell that story
of what it will be like for you and the
other characters who were first to leave
the vaults but there is one big
difference with this game it's that each
of those characters is a real person
[Applause]
because yes fallout 76 is entirely
online
okay I know there's a lot you have like
a thousand questions right now so I'm
gonna go through them in order now I'll
had a couple of the big ones first
of course you can play this solo all
right you'll you'll be who you want
exploring a huge world doing quests
experiencing a story and leveling up we
love those things about our games too it
would not have it any other way but also
like many of you we have always wanted
to see what our style of game could be
with multiplayer so many of us talk
about experiences in our games but we've
never experienced them together so about
four years ago we hit upon an idea that
is perfect for Fallout open world
survival every person and character is
real and it was an idea that we just
couldn't shake we knew we had to do it
and do it in a really big way now I know
you may have played survival modes and
like some of our previous games or some
other online games and we you know
people wonder is this hardcore survival
I like to think of it maybe it's more
softcore survival
maybe that should be a new ESRB
descriptor death never means the loss of
progression or the loss of your
character your character isn't tied to
one server as a matter of fact you'll
never even see a server when you play
you'll be in a world with dozens not
hundreds and not thousands of other
players it's the apocalypse it's not an
amusement park okay
and you'll be able to join your friends
whenever you want and all of your
progression goes with you
when we think about games we think about
worlds and the choices that you can make
the stories that you create and tell
yourself by creating a wide open world
with very few rules we have a game more
than any game that we've ever done where
the choices are yours where you'll
decide what happens you will decide the
heroes and you'll decide the villains
look this is a whole new world for all
of us here and fortunately our friends
at vaulteq have made a series of
informational videos for when all of us
have merged together
[Applause]
[Music]
as you venture out into this new
American frontier some of your fellow
survivors may not be neighborly
chin up there sport not old vault 76
dwellers will be so hostile find them
and brave the new world together whether
you choose to explore the wasteland
alone or with friends your days will be
filled with fun activities
muhuali
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
like previous fallouts you can play this
game solo inquests but the easiest way
to survive in the wasteland is to team
up and build together and in this one
you can build wherever you want and you
can also then move that to wherever you
want
[Music]
after thermonuclear war man's towering
industrial marvels may no longer stretch
to the heavens what separates man from
Beast it is his desire to build get
started with enhance the construction
and assembling mobile platform construct
your home of the future with your homes
secure you can now craft handmade
ordnance at your leisure
to give your altercations that personal
touch it falls on you and the ingenuity
of your fellows to rebuild the America
we hold dear
but don't become too attached too
quickly monitor your environment for
anything out of the ordinary
the home of tomorrow may undergo certain
challenges
after a crisis work with your neighbors
to ensure success
there's no I in nuclear wasteland
document your adventures your memories
will shape the new American dream what's
that sound
there goes the neighborhood we love
dynamic game systems so we thought why
don't we put multiple nuclear missile
sites on the map and then let all of you
do whatever you want with them
today's episode Atomics for peace when
you emerge from the comfort and safety
of your vault the world you know will
have changed take your friendly old
neighbor Johnny rather than coming over
to borrow a cup of sugar he may now be
coming over for murder the time has come
to seek out greater means of protection
nuclear armaments that's right
courtesy of your Uncle Sam these wonders
of the atomic age can be found right in
your own backyard
but how does a fellow like you acquire
nuclear weapons you may ask begin by
inquiring with the locals gently coax
them into cooperation use a little elbow
grease if you have to
in the likely event you don't acquire a
full code on your own do not give up
search for others who might be harboring
a grudge you'll have that nuclear launch
code in no time with the power of the
atom at your fingertips be responsible
and consider your target carefully
attention launch sequence activated
will your bomb land on a rival camp of
degenerates a random stranger the local
wildlife
whatever your target may be take
advantage of the resulting fallout to
gather rare and valuable resources
yet these rewards don't come without
risk
the fate of this new world is yours to
command with the power of the atom we
know you've played a lot of our games
and a lot of online games but this one
really is unique we have built a
platform a hundred percent dedicated
servers that will support this game now
and for years to come and look look we
know this is new for all of you it's new
for us it's a little bit scary and to
that end we're gonna need your help
because yes we are going to have a beta
and it is sponsored by our friends at
vaulteq as well the break-in early tests
application
because evidently these online games are
hard they can have some nasty issues I I
read on the internet that our games have
had a few bugs I did I read it on the
internet so it's true and that sometimes
it doesn't just work anyway we know
together that we are going to build
something really special and we also
know that all of you love our special
editions and we have an awesome
collector's edition for you it starts
with a map of the world that closed in
the [ __ ] dark
yes right so cool
it comes with figures you can put on the
map and it also comes with the fallout
collectible that really I've always
wanted so we made them for everybody to
buy and here it is straighten up and fly
right straighten up and fly right
straighten up and fly right cool down
papa don't you blow your top ain't no
use in diving
what's the use of diving cool down Papa
don't you blow your top
you
[Music]
[Applause]
yes all of this the fallout 76 power
armor edition so you're probably
wondering when is this game coming out
we're excited to say that it's coming
out this year
[Applause]
thanks again for all your support of
Fallout it's been ten years since
fallout 3 our very first one and it's
been an incredible journey with all of
you we do have another fallout
anniversary that we are celebrating here
at e3 it is the three year anniversary
of fallout shelter which we announced
and released right here at e3 and we
have some cool surprises for you
fallout shelter is coming to the
PlayStation 4 and because that guy said
it it's also coming to the Nintendo
switch you can play it with the joy cons
or touch controls and yes it's still
free
[Applause]
and excited to say these versions are
coming out tonight
[Applause]